okay I'm going to start by saying a few
words about the final examination and
I'm saying if you know with the video on
so that those few students who are not
actually here can actually know what my
remarks about the final exam are the
formal assignment will be sent to
everyone by email
probably on Thursday I mentioned in the
very first meeting of this class what
the final exam would be and I want to
elaborate upon that in the textbook that
we're using the earth of its people's by
the end of next week we will have gotten
through the next to the last chapter
that ends with the end of the Cold War
the final chapter which in the fifth
edition was pretty good but in the fifth
brief edition is terrible because I
wrote a little fifth and colleague
relatively brief I'm not going to ask
you to read the final chapter though
you're certainly free to to read it it
actually is a conflation of two chapters
that had originally constituted the most
approximate part of the narrative of
world history and instead for the final
exam I want you to write an outline of
what you think should be the last
chapter of a book a textbook on world
history now what I mean by an outline is
a title for the chapter a list of
the what we call the a heads that is to
say the of the primary divisions of the
chapter a list of the B heads
which means these sub headings under the
primary headings the a heads should
probably not go beyond 5 but he could
have as few as three of the B heads
should probably not go beyond three or
four and I want to have a paragraph
explaining why you have chosen the
topics that you've chosen as being the
proper ones the time span for the
chapter is 1991 to the present what how
you want to define the present is part
of the decision that you will make
although in a textbook ordinarily you
bring your final chapter up as close as
you can to the date of of use so that
you prove to your end-users that that
history is still going on and the
authors are keeping up with it
and I also want on the final part of it
would be the the introduction to the to
the chapters as you will notice by the
incredibly close scrutiny you have given
to all the previous chapters in the book
the introduction to each chapter is
basically a a narrative piece often
singling out a single incident or
personality but it could be more
theoretical than that and it should be
something like let's say 200 words long
so basically I want I'm going to give a
take-home examination that will be
asking you to write let's say
fifteen or so paragraphs
and it will be due on the date of the
final exam scheduled for this course but
I can't remember what that date is we do
not have an in-class final now in in
thinking about how do you organize
history from 1991 onward well you're
free to use anything anything you like
one of the great problems of history is
thinking about contemporary history as
some people call it let's say the
history either that is transpired during
your lifetime or within the lifetimes of
people to whom you have easy access for
many years I had a seminar in which for
graduate students usually first-year
graduate students and my assignment the
first assignment in the seminar I would
pick a year like I would pick if it's
now 2011 I would pick say Oh 2008 and
the assignment would be in three pages
write a history of the year 2008 with
the understanding you cannot consult any
written sources whatsoever you can talk
to people you can remember but you
cannot look anything up you can cheat by
talking to someone and saying would you
go to Wikipedia and look up such and
such but I would not reward that in
particular because I was trying to do
was to pose for graduate students the
kind of challenge that chroniclers
throughout history have have faced until
fairly recent times that is to say they
you know you in some ways the most
important part of the assignment was
that the three pages long because if
you're writing a chronicle there has to
be a limit to how much you you put in
there's only three pages it means that
you have to select and so the problem of
selection which if you're writing an
exhaustive you know six volume history
of the American Civil War or something
maybe you put in everything you know but
the fact of the matter is most
historians most of the time are
selecting and the the the more general
the history the greater the challenge of
selection not only the selection of
topics but the selection of what data or
or anecdote and so forth
best fits the topic that has been
selected and then I threw in they
provides other that you could not
consult with anyone or that that you
could not consult any written sources
simply because throughout most of
history people who were comprising who
are compiling annals had no access to
records you know now we can go back and
say oh we can find the archives of
such-and-such or here's some
correspondence preserved and so forth
but if you were in a let's say a
preprint era or even in the print era
most people who are going to write down
stories about what happened didn't have
access to a broad array of archival
materials they might have access to one
or two and nowadays will read back and
say well so-and-so no good old you know
venerable bede new this document we
didn't know there's other document well
it's really tough to do this sort of
thing without documents but that's a
challenge and of course are the
histories that we now have are heavily
compiled heavily dependent on
compilations by people who did not have
access to to archives and when you look
at the strategies they have for dealing
with it which you won't have to do for
the
exam because I'm not asking you to bring
us finished copy but of course one of
the things you can do is simply make it
all up you can say you know in this year
general so-and-so invaded Baghdad and he
confronted the Calif and the Calif said
you know hey why are you invading
baghdad and the general said you are a
slimeball and going to trample you with
elephants they said no no I'm innocent
and then you can just invent dialogues
we have invented dialogues invented
stories invented anecdotes particularly
invented numbers that have been around
for hundreds in some cases thousands of
years and which frankly a lot of our
history today relies on that clearly are
not valid numbers or valid conversations
but they're so vivid so when I would do
this assignment that I would have the
students all read aloud their three-page
history of the year and depending on
their background or their interests the
you have most remarkable contributions
there was one year in which a a woman
wrote a detailed account of her work for
the Redevelopment Authority and say
Danbury Connecticut and she'd say you
know on August 12th the vacant JP Penney
store was reoccupied by
a by an elder center and she went down
street by street
what were the landmark moments on the
rebuilding of Danbury and at the end of
the of the class when everyone had read
their piece we had sort of a vote as to
who wrote the best history of the year
and it was almost unanimous everyone
agreed that she had done the best
history
and so I said is it true and there was
this pause and she said no she said you
know damn Barry did have this rebuilding
but I don't actually remember the dates
or the specific names but I thought it
would make a better history if I fleshed
it out and it did everyone thought that
was a great history it just didn't
happen to be a true history in one time
when I the Year assigned was 1978
they'll be build up to the Iranian
Revolution the three Iranians in the
class all wrote a history of the Iranian
Revolution none of them had been in Iran
during the time so none of them had any
first-hand experience they'd all been
students the United States there were
two Americans who had been in Iran
during the entire period and they wrote
their histories about US politics and
never mentioned your honor and it's it
was a good lesson in how where you focus
depends more on who you are than in a
sense on where you are and one year
there were two Chinese students from the
People's Republic and they wrote what
were for all intents and purposes
identical essays although the the the
man included a the outcome of a key
football match between Hong Kong and the
PRC or something like that as a high
point of the air whereas the woman did
not and so I asked them how did you come
to write the same thing they said well
this is what we were taught and I said
well you you say that such and such
happened to are you sure it happened in
this year say oh no we have no idea
whether it happened in this year and up
but this is you know our version
virtually been taught of what happened
in that that point in our history and
there were many really you're seeing
examples a one irani ins student wrote a
detailed history of Ethiopia for that
year month by month and so forth and it
was all I could do to keep myself from
going and checking to see whether any of
it was true at all and to this day I
think that he simply invented it
completely out of whole cloth the names
of general so-and-so and print so-and-so
and the coup and the vist of that and
that he was simply putting me on in the
entire and the entire assignment because
these are all the but I always tried to
point out was that these are all real
options what a historian writes is
whatever the historian damn-well chooses
to write if that historian is a
card-carrying member of the historians
guild or a tenured professor at a major
university they will be expected to
write within certain parameters of
resource checking but most history isn't
written by people like that it's written
by people who are who are it's a freer
in their in their sense of what is
needed or expected of course I've always
wanted to teach but never have is a
seminar on family history where everyone
would be expected in the course of the
Subedar to write the history of their
own family because I'm convinced that
every family is full of family stories
and that they're all lies and that being
forced to dredge up you know that
recollection from
aunt so-and-so or what you think your
grandfather may have done and then throw
it before a class and government who
discuss it about well is it really
plausible that she did sit on George
Washington's knee while he fed her mush
and milk as is a claim for ancestor in
my family of course you look up the
dates and you find that you know the
woman and in question wasn't born when
George Washington was alive so it
couldn't possibly have happened but
families continually invent stories
about themselves or mystery member or
remember selectively you know the you
know cousin so-and-so who's in prison
never gets mentioned Oh cousin so-and-so
who you know who died heroically will
get mentioned a lot I recall when my
mother was away my father took me aside
showed me the family tree that he had
compiled he said now your mother isn't
around so I can tell you this is cousin
olive and she's in the penitentiary and
your mother won't want you to know that
so then he told me about how cousin
olive came to be in prison and two three
years later the charming woman
knocked on the door is it hi I'm your
cousin outlet but I thought oh when did
you get out of stir you know so my wife
I hated it if I mentioned that a cousin
who is in prison in a state of
Washington for child molestation
he's writes a lot of poetry in prison
there's a lot of free time I've never
met him but she said well you don't you
don't mention those things well of
course historians cannot rely upon this
sort of selectivity being the best way
to
to construct a narration so anyway what
I'm when I'm this is a sort of a
digression because I maybe I just don't
have enough to say today but the but the
fact matter is in the final exam is the
exam on asking you how to structure a
history from 1991 onwards now in a way
that's that's a particularly difficult
burden because as I said the closer you
get to your own times both the greater
the opportunities and the and the the
greater the you know let's say the fewer
the limitations and it can be very
difficult to decide what you want to
write and I would apply that to the
entire 20th century and not just to the
let's say the last decade plus the 21st
century and so far as we have had it a
couple of weeks ago I was talking about
20th century history and the more I look
at the way we have done it in this
textbook the more questions I have so
that the the chapter that we have a sign
for today or for this week is a chapter
about independence in Latin America
South Asia and Africa in the period from
1900 to 1949 probably the most Awkward
chapter of the entire book and one which
will not appear in the sixth edition as
well what you have here for the
twentieth century let's say what we and
so many people do is start with the long
19th century as it's called that is say
world history up to World War one and
then we have
World War one the Great Depression World
War two and end the Cold War that is the
structure of the narrative as it appears
in a preponderance of of textbook
approaches so what we've done is stick a
chapter in here after World War Two but
before the Cold War that deals with
problems in the non euro-american
sino-japanese orbit during the period
1900 1949 because of course one of the
great one of the problems of this
sequence here as the of the dominant
narrative and is that it really is a
euro-american and sino-japanese story
it's not a world story but it is still
received as the great story of the 20th
century and the story that if you were
to leave it out it would be felt that
you had done something really wrong now
last week I talked about Steven Pinker's
book about declining violence and he
makes this rather curious argument that
the that this narrative particularly the
world war one world war two part of it
constitutes giving a privileged position
to two anomalies or perhaps one big
collective anomaly of a pinnacle of
violence over in the midst of a
long-term decline in violence and he
argues that it's the period precisely
since the end of World War two
that shows where we are in the world
today and that we're it in a world that
was largely at peace the Cold War never
turned into a shooting war except of
course at Korea and Vietnam and half a
dozen whole places and and the peace
continuous so he calls it the great
peace not long peace and he says you
know you look back in 20th century quite
look at the first half when it's the
second half that is your harbinger of
things to come and the first half was a
horrible nightmare that you can afford
to forget because it was anomalous it
was outside the long-term trend now I've
spoken somewhat disparagingly of this
theory last week I'm not going to go
into it again but it does raise a
question of for those things that don't
fit in this narrative arc what do you do
do you mention them before or do you
mention them after so that you know you
look at you say you're doing it after
and you go back let's say to the Mexican
Revolution and Pancho Villa and things
that were going on at the turn of the
century and then you carry it forward
and you give the history of Mexico since
that time or you go back to the history
of Brazil the history of Argentina circa
1800 circa 1900 and then you carry the
story forward to 1949 in order to
provide a you know to convince people
that you're doing world history you
can't leave out the Western Hemisphere
let's say the non-english speaking
western hemisphere
on the other hand where do you put it in
it doesn't fit in the big narrative
similarly a South Asian so this chapter
will go back to the late British period
in South Asia in the post 1857
occupation of India and we'll tell the
story of the rise of independence
movements how a million Indian soldiers
participated in World War one
enthusiastically on the British side but
how after the war there was a strong
mobilization toward toward achieving
independence and who leads that
mobilization its Mahatma Gandhi now
Gandhi all by himself provides a story
that nobody can afford to leave out and
you think you know when you have
political movements provide political
leaders today who are the comparisons
that you have on the bad side you can
always compare somebody with Hitler no
good old Saddam Hussein is the you know
the like Hitler or I'm Aneta jobs like
Hitler or you know your boss at work is
like Hitler I mean you always have have
a nice comparison on the bad side on the
good side how far back do you go does
anyone ever say you know what we need is
a statesman like Bismarck say well it's
only the 1870s but who remembers
anything worth remembering about
Bismarck except he presided over German
unification and what a triumph that
turned out to be or do you say you know
we need people like Abraham Lincoln well
nobody really goes back quite that far
but Gandhi
is cited you know thousands of times as
the sort of paragon of what what a a
peaceful and successful resistance to to
autocracy or authoritarian rule should
be like who else is later you'll Martin
Luther King you of Gandhi Martin Luther
King's recent you go back to Gandhi is
there anyone before Gandhi now Mandela's
since Gandhi so but is there any model
of a good political person prior to
Gandhi
well there's Jesus and I do not
disparage people who in their private
moments say well what would Jesus do he
was a good model in many respects not
all respects he was never commanded an
army in battle but let's let's say
between Jesus and Gandhi who do you who
do you come up with if you're a Muslim
you can come up with Mohammed and they
do and that's an important exception but
but by and large the memory people have
only goes back a fairly short way in
terms of thinking in comparative terms
that are personal and you might compare
the United States as a toppling Empire
with the post August and Roman Empire or
something or with the post Charlemagne
you know Frankish Empire you might do an
institutional comparison but if you're
talking about people who are whose names
are talismans of political significance
you just don't go back very far you go
back to JFK to agree anybody remembers
what he actually did or a thought or
stood for the founding fathers now seem
a little quaint say you know
I really want to be like Charles Carroll
of Carrollton or you know button
Gwinnett or some one of the other
signers with Declaration of Independence
but the thing is with Gandhi is that you
can't write the history of 20th century
without putting him in but he doesn't
fit into the narrative arc of World War
one the depression in World War two but
he's in the same time frame so where do
you put them do you go back and you say
well that's that's deal with Latin
America Africa and and South southern
Asia to 1949 before we have told the
story of the world wars well then
everyone will say well that that's
obviously a stupid thing to do because
the context in which these things
transpired including Gandhi's
immobilization of a nationalist movement
of India that context was shaped by by
the Wars but can you do it later
yeah okay the question is because their
way around am I making World War one the
beginning of a decolonizing century and
that of course is it's tempting because
the next the next chapter in the book is
on Cold War and decolonization although
probably in the next day or so be called
decolonization and cold war or but the
problem of decolonization is that so
much of it is contingent on the outcomes
of the wars that it's unless you've
decided to to replace the war narrative
with the deed with the end of empire
narrative then you could do it but of
course you then people would say well
what happened to to the great wars in
the long around the great wars are going
to be diminished and probably folded
together and other narratives are going
to emerge particularly as those
countries that were not engaged
primarily in the great Wars begin to
play a greater role in contemporary
history other words the story of Brazil
is one that scarcely any non Latin
American specialists or Brazil
specialists bothers to read and yet in
another 25 years the importance of
Brazil may be so unquestionable that it
will be necessary to go back and and
talk about Brazil
same thing with India obviously so it's
you know you you could look at it as the
first stage of decolonization but then
it's also messing up some of your other
narrative lines
another possibility would be to to say
let's look at something that's in a
longer term a constant recurrent and
seemingly irresolvable problem how do
you pay for war now you do that and you
can go back to the pretty much the
origin of gunpowder if not before and
then you probably go back before you can
say you know one of the paradoxes of
history is that warfare recurs that
warfare is engaged in by people who are
in quest of victory and they see victory
as being a materially beneficial to them
sometimes our wars that are fought more
in revenge rather than for material gain
but let's stick here with the ones that
are fought with the notion that the
victor will come out with some benefit
but the problem for both the the
prospective victor and the prospective
loser is how do you pay for the war the
number of convulsions that are
experienced by different countries over
a period of several centuries that are
triggered by a lack of money or not so
much lack of money but by the by the
production of worthless money to pay for
the war these are these are innumerable
you know the question of war and
national income is a constant a constant
vexation down down to the present day
national income is something that is
measurable it rises hopefully in you
know steady usually modest increments
you can calculate what your revenues may
be and so forth whereas Wars is exactly
the opposite it's the expense is
unpredictable the the expense increments
in in ways that you can rarely foresee
and in order to fight wars in the last
several centuries people have either had
to borrow money which then produces huge
problems of repayment or they have had
to to produce fiat money fiat is the
Latin term for let it be done in the in
Roman Imperial decrees you'd have the
text of the decree presented to the
Empire Emperor and he would write Fiat
let it be done
so fiat money is simply money you know a
sum something that is declared to be
money by the government and that takes
place not exclusively in times of war
but again and again in times of war
where are you you produce money because
you have to you have expenses you have
to buy goods you have to pay troops you
have to do this in that but you don't
really want you don't really have the
money to do it and so you you invent
money and then at the end of the war you
try to recover that worthless money and
replace it with with with money that is
worthwhile to try and retire the due
bills unless you are a loser in which
case the money is just worthless and
everyone who has it is lost you know
that accounts for the few Confederate
banknotes I have in a box and under my
son's bed or the nice sheaf of
uncirculated beautifully printed
banknotes strong on the central bank of
Chihuahua that were produced by Pancho
Villa during his period of brief power
in the early 20th century in northern
Mexico money is totally worthless
so winners are sometimes able to pay
back the money and retire the fiat money
and losers simply simply lose the thing
about money is that increasingly over
time
it stretches beyond the national borders
and the nature of borrowing is not
always contained with him within
national boundaries so there will be a
time saying medieval period where the
merchants or the or the Jews or other
people who were felt to have a lot of
money will basically have the government
come to them and say you're now going to
loan your money to the government
let's say they're going to steal it and
we'll pay it back for you to some time
and maybe they do and maybe they don't
then that goes to you know a little
further on and you find your borrow
you're going to bankers in other
countries and borrowing the money
instead of bankers in your own country
or merchants up there was a concept that
arose that was supposed to deal with
this in some way and that was the notion
of a gold standard and that is what sort
of lay the foundation for for the 20th
century a monetary regime some problems
that come into being the gold standard
arises in the 1820s it's not an old
concept the notion that gold or silver
or copper or you know peanut shells or
anything else would be currency as an
entirely arbitrary cultural
decision there's no intrinsic value to
anything except of course profit oriole
lectures at Columbia University but but
the gold standard declared that all
money that is produced should be
convertible to gold and that the amount
of money that is available will be a
direct a direct multiple of the of the
amount of gold that is available doesn't
say if you say an ounce of gold is worth
so many pound sterling that will be or
fixed multiple and the idea was that
countries have had gold their currency
would fluctuate according to how much
gold they had and this was visualized as
a homeostatic system one that was
self-correcting in every respect so that
supposing you had a country that
exported more than it imported so people
were buying goods from this country and
the country was acquiring gold or
acquiring money that was convertible in
the gold so that meant that the total
gold stock of the country was increasing
and then in the theory as a gold stock
increased the government would turn the
gold into into cones or into cash
convertible into gold and increase the
money supply because they had more gold
and so they could increase the money
supply this would increase prices
because you wouldn't have necessarily an
increase in the number of goods produced
but rather you would have more more
money chasing the same quantity of goods
so you would have an inflation this is
called the price effect the price would
go up and when the price went up that
meant that the
the price of the goods you were
exporting became more difficult for
overseas importers to afford so they
would bring in a fewer of your products
and your wealthy people would buy you
know more foreign products and pay more
for them and you would end up
stabilizing everything by having a
modest inflation then it was the other
way around and you you imported more
than you exported then that would mean
that you were losing gold and when you
lost gold the quantity of money that you
could afford to have in circulation
would go down and therefore you would
deflate the economy and everybody would
suffer from a certain amount of
austerity until things even out your
prices go down making your goods more
more affordable in international trade
and therefore your trade balance comes
back into equilibrium so the gold
standard was predicated on the notion
that the balance of trade among world's
economies was what needed to be kept in
equilibrium it was very different from
some earlier economic theories that said
that that the wealth of a country was
simply the quantity of gold without
taking trade into account but this
notion of having the balance of trade be
determined strictly by price and income
factors related to the gold supply which
in turn was directly related to the
money supply was the heart and soul of
the concept of free trade and free trade
became the the great dream of 19th
century business people those countries
that had colonies did not believe in
free trade with their colonies
they thought that they should have a
special privilege in the colonial market
but countries without colonies like the
United States or countries that wanted
to do trade where they did not have a
colony even if they were Imperials
elsewhere for example the British
selling opium to the Chinese these in
these situations business took the gold
standard very seriously and the balance
of trade between countries very
seriously this whole system did not work
nearly as well in practice as it was
supposed to in theory and certain
colonial economies were that did not
have much in the way of gold were
buffeted by the ebb and flow of gold
reserves particularly in Britain so that
a country like argentina brazil would go
through cycles of boom and bust in the
early in the late 19th early 20th
century according to what was happening
in the in the currency balance in
Britain you realize that Britain was
unfathomably rich circa 1900 from its
colonial possessions so that Britain
exported every year for decades
something around 5% of its gross
national product in overseas investment
so the British invested everywhere and
that of course meant that any
perturbation of the currency exchanges
in Britain would cause people to
withdraw investment or extend investment
and this was particularly felt in these
colonial colonial areas say Britch and
the France in Germany were exporting
something more like Oh 2% or even under
2 percent of gross national product in
terms of overseas investment
at the same time all right
this went along it was very good for the
people who had gold the British the
French the Germans the Americans were a
problem because you had a strong
political movement in America to to
detach America from the gold standard
but that failed and prices that would
have gone down if we had shifted to a to
a free silver standard stayed high which
was good for American balance of trade
but when it came to a war remember if
this is coming into effect in the 1820s
this is after the fall of Napoleon and
there is no major war in Europe from
then until until World War one there are
some Wars like the franco-prussian war
of 1870 or the austro-prussian war these
are very brief Wars and the amount of
money that you had to pony up to fight
the war was more or less affordable
colonial wars were the financial
investment in colonial wars was less
than it would be in a European war
because if you used local troops they
were much cheaper than if you were
bringing out troops from the from the
metropolitan center so basically the
gold standard back you know economic
system was having a fair degree of
stability for the major financial powers
in the world down to World War one then
came World War one and the war that was
supposed to end quickly dragged on for
four years
the country's involved except the United
States became deeply deeply dependent on
fiat money they simply printed money so
by the war's end there their currency no
longer was convertible into gold but
they became obsessed with the idea that
they must return to the gold standard
and they took measures to try and do so
the classic measure would be that if you
had too much money in circulation rid
relation to how much gold you have that
you should impose a recession but we
would now call a recession or a
deflation so in Britain after the war
the government limited the amount of
money to try and get back on the gold
standard and created massive
unemployment and an economic depression
in France the conviction of the French
government and central bankers was that
they could get all the money they needed
from Germany which proved not to be the
case and in Germany they went for
massive inflation - sort of magic the
debts away but I've mentioned this
before out of this comes the the sort of
frantic years of the 1920s followed by
the Great Depression of the 1930s but
for other parts of the world that did
not play a role in the war they were
drawn into the aftermath they had to
deal with the financial consequences but
for people in many colonial areas those
financial consequences seemed like an
opportunity
you take a country like Egypt during
World War one the British were in
occupation of Egypt they had been
occupying Egypt since 1881 they had an
army based in Egypt that fought to
prevent the Ottomans from seizing the
Suez Canal but of course they had to
feed that army and equip that army and
how are they going to do that they
couldn't ship goods very easily from
England because England was you know in
difficult straits in terms of supplying
itself and shipping was very difficult
so what they did was simply take the
money from the Egyptians they would say
well we need so much food so we will
commandeer the food that we need and
we'll carry it on the books as a loan
from you it wasn't a voluntary loan by
the end of the war Egypt technically was
very rich because they had these huge
you know bookkeeping surpluses that they
gained by essentially commandeered or
forced loan relations with the British
and that wasn't the only country to be
in that situation to find that they were
they had not been borrowing money to
fight the war because most of them
weren't fighting the war at least not
directly but they were supplying goods
at a at a price and now they had
balances that they wanted to to bring
home and it gave it can it it conduced
to a feeling of political power that you
know instead of being constantly
imposed upon financially now they they
felt they had some sort of some sort of
leverage visa via the colonial powers in
Egypt that took the form of a sending a
delegation to the or trying to sell them
to go delegation of the peace conference
in India takes the form of the
nationalist movement that Gandhi leads
but in various parts of the world the
economic consequences of the war and the
subsequent disarray of European finances
led people in the colonies to feel that
that may be the the great edifice of
colonialism is is weakening the Great
Depression compounded this although it
brought more misery than opportunity but
that was spread widely then you come to
World War Two and the gold standard has
never been restored prior to World War
Two the only country that has a lot of
gold is the United States the the
question of how to fight World War two
is a huge question for the for the
powers World War two costs you know an
enormous amount of money at the end of
World War two the question of what money
do the colonial powers have left to to
engage with the nationalist forces in
their in their various imperial
possessions that became a crucial
question does Britain
now here you have in India provided a
million troops in world war 1 2 million
participants in world war 2 not all his
troops India felt that they were owed
something Britain had promised them
something with absolutely no sincerity
to the promise as far as anyone can tell
but now was Britain in a position to
fight to keep India and the answer was
no if you had not had World War two
would the Congress party in India have
successfully uh negotiated the partition
that took place making India and
Pakistan independent states well
probably not
it's the impoverishment of Britain that
is key not only in India but throughout
the British Empire
so the decolonization which sometimes
appears to be a product of enlightenment
that as if countries suddenly said you
know we've just been oppressing you for
so long and we've been disrespecting you
and you know we've decided to just turn
over the keys to you and we're going
home this was not him you know an
enlightened kind of act this was the
necessity of the financial burdens of
the war compounded by the human losses
of war now you might say well the human
losses are more important that Britain
didn't have an army to send to India but
Britain had a large enough army to hold
on to Palestine
well okay why bother but they did have
enough I mean that was but the cost the
cost in monetary terms in human terms
and I think increasingly in kind of
moral terms it just didn't seem worth it
to to the British and so when you look
at the colonial wars that the British
fight there they are primarily before
World War one then you have more little
hiatus down to the end of World War two
and then you have independence and you
don't have much in the way of wars for
the French on the other hand it's very
different the French had not been as
overwhelmed in World War two with their
British because they lost the war early
on and they still saw their colonial
territories as places that were going to
yield wealth of their way if their
solution to World War one was to get
money to pay their debts from the
Germans their solution to world war two
was to go back into Indochina and
Algeria in particular and an extract the
wealth they needed to to rebuild their
economy rebuild the the country at home
this led to two horrible wars war in
Vietnam or at least French share of it
and then the war in Algeria that ends in
1961 the Dutch had every intention of
staying in Indonesia no Holland is this
big and Indonesia is this big and there
was so much money to be made if you
could hold on to it Indonesia
that this would rescue the Dutch but
they simply didn't have the money or the
manpower the capacity to to do it
so the decolonization and this is where
that point you were just making earlier
really is important is that
decolonization that in our textbook and
in many other accounts of the 20th
century is seen as something that is a
post-world War two phenomenon is an
outcome of of a much longer sequence of
things in which the movement of Gandhi
will stand out for its symbolic and
moral weight but it isn't simply a
matter of what people in colonial areas
are able to muster in terms of local
political power but it's also the the
balance of capacity that you have
between the colonial Metropole and the
various colonies that are under its rule
the financial burdens of World War one
the depression in World War two
destroyed imperialism by destroying the
capacity of the imperialist powers to
continue as they have this can be seen
of course as a series of effective
national struggles for liberation and
that's true you have successful national
struggles for liberation whether they
are in Vietnam or in with Ho Chi Minh or
in Indonesia with with sukarno or in
India with Gandhi's successors but
without the the debilitation of the
imperial powers there I don't see any
particular reason to think that that
imperialism would have disappeared in
the second half of the 20th century
crimean war is only eighteen 1850s yeah
the Crimean War was moderately expensive
it didn't last all that long and the
primary burdens of of expense in the
Crimean War were on Turkey and are the
Ottoman Empire in Russia rather than on
Britain in France but written perhaps
France paid a fair amount of money for
it but compared with these later wars
that the Crimean was was pretty
insignificant same thing with the Boer
War so you could say well let's look at
the twentieth century as a as a long
episode of economic history and if you
do that then you get into the efforts at
the end of World War two to create a new
economic system efforts that created the
International Monetary Fund and the
World Bank neither of which has ever
functioned on the scale and with the
effectiveness as was visualized you go
back to 1945 46 and you'll find John
Maynard Keynes who's advocating that
there should be a new currency in the
world at least for for accounting
purposes called the bank or and the bank
or would be an international currency
that all countries would would be party
to through a World Bank that was truly a
world bank that all countries would be
party to it never it never came about
the Americans did not want it but a lot
of other people did not want it as well
so the the the agreements that were made
about international finance in the late
40s were not adequate to deal with the
with the results of of the war and it
ended up with the United
States as the main source of usable
wealth in the world for a period of time
this took the form of the Marshall Plan
for European powers that had fought
against against Hitler and Mussolini
which was bad luck for the Spaniards
because they had been neutral during the
war and therefore they didn't get any of
the money until they joined NATO the men
they got a bonus for being part of NATO
in Japan it took the form of the Korean
War where the amount of money the u.s.
paid for two base forces in Japan and to
buy logistic goods locally in Japan to
pay for the to supply the troops in
Korea this was the great
this was the Marshall Plan for Japan
this is what fed money into the into the
Japanese economy that made the great
Japanese industrial advances of the 60s
and 70s possible the United States thus
on a in world financial terms becomes
what England had been in 1900 and this
then becomes a problem with the very
broad look at world history that in this
country has tried to minimize the role
of the United States you know in high
schools and colleges American history is
taught as a separate subject and is the
most popular area of history for pretty
much every history department in the
country so world history textbooks in
world history courses
take it as a given that the students
already know or are taking or will
familiarize themselves with American
history
and therefore we won't talk too much
about America so the American Revolution
is there in sort of a brief form the
Civil War is barely talked about it's
not until you get to 1898 and the
spanish-american war where America
starts to act in an imperialistic
fashion although you have some previous
episodes in Latin America that the
United States sort of shows up on the
scene and then it shows up even more in
World War one because we send troops to
Europe in World War one and Woodrow
Wilson plays a significant rhetorical
role in dealing with the outcome of
World War one but then the United States
is less than dominating in the interwar
period until you get to World War Two
where the United States plays a very
very important role and ends up with a
ton of money and also with a with an
economy that is skillfully managed in
the late 40s and 50s in order to provide
employment and consumer goods and so
forth for for the American home market a
substantial inflation to keep that going
but by and large compared with the way
many countries handle the ends of wars
in terms of the domestic economy United
States handle it quite well during the
Eisenhower be highs in our era or the
Truman Eisenhower era
but America now becomes the the leader
of financial concerns on a worldwide
basis and how do you handle that when
you're writing history you say the u.s.
just suddenly appears twelve the money
or how do you how do you calculate that
and how do you how do you see it
affecting the way in which America
relates to to the rest of the world the
let me take the the last matter in the
stands like this is this is a temporary
phenomenon we had lots of money in the
40s and 50s now Saudi Arabia and Qatar
have lots of money and China has lots of
money and we don't so it's it's a
temporary phenomenon and if you're
looking in the long term you look at the
continuing American expenses for wars
whether it is Vietnam or Korea or Iraq
Afghanistan or the great armaments
expenses the cold war the peace dividend
that we had at the end of World War two
got got spent or less but we didn't have
any replacements until the the oil
crises of more recent times and the rise
of China briefly before that Japan
so you can talk about the emergency
united states some people who will write
about the 20th century was the american
century dubious proposition but one that
could be argued for say the period Oh
you know 1965 or something like that it
might work but when a country moves
either to a position of supremacy of
great power status or from such a
position the impact upon the the
thinking of people who consider
themselves rightly or wrongly as being
players in the in the political or the
policy making game that impact is is
terribly important because it then
shapes the intellectual climate that you
have but that you have at any particular
point in time in my view the events of
9/11 have underlied the current
political climate of the United States
which is not exactly you know world
supremacy and as it might have been in
the JFK or Nixon era but going back
earlier the the Americans who came out
of World War two
and went into government and into
international thinking going into
considering the world and this would
include a fair number of people who went
into businesses that became increasingly
engaged in international affairs or
international business activities they
seemed to have had the feeling that you
know if we could beat the Nazis and the
Japanese we could do anything and we
should if you want to write a history of
comparative hubris you could say well
America in the 50s and maybe written in
the 1860s or 70s and France under Louis
the fourteenth and you can go back and
you say you know there are these periods
when you have countries and it's very
difficult to to you know sort of talk
about a country in this way but but it's
really the mindset of leadership
elements in countries where their points
were that where they think we really can
do anything because you know you know we
are smart and we are able and we are
determined and by George people like us
it's it's a very strange moment the
United States in the 1950s and at least
the early 60s produced a phenomenal
absolute final number of world-shaking
new ideas
and our world girdling new ideas I
should say ideas that were meant to
explain the nature of human activity the
nature of the world system the nature of
money and its function in the world it
was the Americans who had these ideas
and most of them were wrong
but whether they were right or wrong is
a matter of retrospect they were
convinced that they were right they
proceeded to function to lead the United
States into a post-war world in which
there was probably nothing more potent
than American self-confidence and that
is the world that we now think of in
somewhat more negative terms as being
the era of of the Cold War which in
retrospect looks increasingly creepy as
a period of national history and for
many of us in this room as a period in
personal history so I'll talk about that
on Thursday